Speaker 1: Let's hear from people, people in
the audience. Because without you, I'm a guy
in a room with a microphone and everybody is
sad and everything is bad. You can call in via
discord at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
And we are going to start today with a very, very
special person. We're starting with Steve from
the Bay Area. Steve, welcome. What's going on?
And Steve is gone. No boy
already having a problem.
Let's go to Thomas from my birth city
of Buenos Aires. Tomas Bienvenido.
Oh, boy.
Speaker 3: Hello.
Speaker 1: Thomas you have a configuration
problem where whatever audio device you
have selected doesn't actually
work because you're unmuted.
And we will give Thomas one last
opportunity to resolve his audio issues.
Hmm. People are telling me they can hear
Tomas. So let's see. Maybe this is my
audio settings. Let's see if I can fix that.
Uh. Let's see here. Thomas, are you with me?
Speaker 3: I am. Oh, well.
Speaker 1: Welcome, welcome,
welcome. That was my fault. I apologize.
Speaker 3: Hello, once again.
Speaker 1: Pleasure.
Speaker 3: Um, I'm not going to ask you
how you're doing, so. Because you said not to.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Yeah, no, I'm doing fine
today. We don't need everybody to ask me how
I'm doing. Tell me what's going on with the
currency these days in Argentina.
Speaker 3: When is it? When is
it ever different? We're doing badly.
Speaker 1: Got it. And what at this point
is everybody operating on the blue dollar?
Speaker 3: Everyone's operating on just.
Not operating.
Speaker 1: Okay,
fair. Fair. Well, what's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: You know, the whole Louisiana
thing that's going on in Argentina?
Speaker 1: No, I have not been following it.
Speaker 3: Basically, I don't know if you remember
a long time ago, we had the. What's it called? The
prosecutor, Nisman. Who killed him? Supposedly.
Speaker 1: Supposedly, yes.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Well, there's a new
prosecutor that is going to prosecute Cristina.
Speaker 1: Oh, yes, yes, yes. No, I didn't know
his name, but I have been following that. Yeah.
Speaker 3: And our president, Alberto, he said
I hope he doesn't kill himself
like the last one did.
Speaker 1: Right. That
would be really sad if that.
Speaker 3: Happened on TV.
Speaker 1: He said that on on Dana. Right.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I saw that. It's completely
insane now. You know, I have friends and
some of them I'm friends with on Facebook. Who
are Christina? Does they just love Christina?
They have been silent since this happened. Now,
I'm sure that down there, some of them are being
very loud, but like, how are they defending this?
Speaker 3: Basically there's like all over
Goleta is just swarming with police with like
kitchenette stuff and stuff. Like everyone's
just in the streets, like all day long.
Speaker 1: What's been your reaction to
that comment? I hope he doesn't kill himself.
Speaker 3: It's ignored. Completely. Ignored.
Speaker 1: Completely. Okay. Yeah, that
makes sense. That's very Trumpian, actually.
Speaker 3: Yeah, it is.
Speaker 1: Just think. Do you think she's
going to end up in prison? In all seriousness?
Speaker 3: I don't. I don't think so.
Speaker 1: Probably not. Right.
Yeah, it just doesn't seem like.
Speaker 3: They never do.
Speaker 1: They never do.
Exactly. Exactly. Wow. Well.
Speaker 3: All right. She did.
It would be there would be, like, riots and stuff.
Speaker 1: They would have to be. Yeah. You know,
Lindsey Graham said if Trump gets indicted,
there will be riots. Just imagine what will
happen if Christine ends up in prison.
Speaker 3: Yeah. People would. A lot of
people would die. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Any new type
of empanada I should be aware of?
Speaker 3: Oh, sorry to hear that.
Speaker 1: Oh, that's interesting. That's sort of
American, isn't it?
Speaker 3: It really
is. It's my favorite time now.
Speaker 1: Wow. And it's just like, is
it a normal hot dog or is it like a nice sausage?
Speaker 3: No, it's a normal hot dog. Just cut up.
Speaker 1: And that's really sad. It's really
sad to see a pinata culture go into the direction
of hot dogs.
Speaker 3:
I mean, it's delicious, so I can't complain.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend. Well,
thank you for the call.
Speaker 3: See ya.
Speaker 1: Thanks, Joe. That
was. Is that. That's depressing